gentlemen shall we join the ladies my
name is John blundell I've known
Margaret Thatcher for 40 years in fact
although I was never on her payroll I
interacted with in every job she ever
had and I'm the author of Margaret
Thatcher a portrait of the Iron Lady
when I first heard about this movie and
that fact that Meryl Streep that was to
play Margaret I was a little worried
because of Meryl Streep's own ideas and
policies and so on that are very
distinctly not that's right
but honest on it to being pleasantly
surprised I think overall that Margaret
comes out of this process with her
reputation enhanced and of course Meryl
Streep's reputation hugely enhanced as
she gets under Margaret's skin in a
credible fashion well it's all very well
to talk about changing my voice mr.
Reese but for some of my colleagues to
imagine me as their leader be like
imagining I don't know being led into
battle by their chambermaid Margaret
sideshow is a very important historical
figure some would say one of the top two
or three prime ministers over the last
couple of hundred years the British
economy was ranked 19th out of 22 in the
OECD countries the unions were running
riot and we were heading south the
nationalized industries were losing
gargantuan amounts of money requiring
huge subsidies everywhere every year and
going downhill she sorted out the unions
she cut marginal tax rates hugely she
got control of the budget
she started privatizing and D
nationalizing and we saw huge
improvements and she made the country
walk tall again
and fundamentally changed the attitude
of people in the country to a free
market based economy she changed it all
and she started the process that brought
peace to Northern Ireland and with
Ronald Reagan and the Pope helped tear
down that wall without a shot being
fired and destroyed the evil empire it
is an astonishing list when you sit down
and make a list of what she achieved
it's astonishing thing is it was a pity
that Ronald Reagan didn't appear he
appears just once dancing with her but
he did that there's no actor with a
speaking part at the main American
politician to interact with Margaret is
Al Haig at the time of the Argentinian
invasion of the Falkland Islands with
all due respect when one has been the
war with all due respect sir I have done
battle every single day of my life and
many men have underestimated me before
this lot seemed bound to do the same but
they will rue the day no shall I be
mother T ow how do you take your tea
black or white the main criticism has
been that it's unfair to make him a
movie about somebody with dementia when
they're still alive I was initially
quite taken with with that idea but I'm
to giving you some thought I thought
well you know she put herself out there
in public life and when you go out there
in public life that the rules about what
you can say and what can be said about
you to change is not as issues a private
individual and the dementia is portrayed
quite sensitively it's not like she's
permanently thinking that her husband is
still alive or what have you
she has her lucid moments there's a
fantastic scene when Margaret is with
her doctor and the doctors asking her
questions about her mental health and
she's clearly lying and she knows she's
lying she's not at that she's just tuned
in at that particular moment and the
doctors phone begins to ring but I do so
appreciate your kind concern
who do please answer that might be
someone who needs you that was classic
Thatcher who ever wrote that almost
deserves an Oscar for just that line I
think people who opposed are beginning
to change their tune a little bit just a
streak began to as the movie went on
Streep began to respect that you more
and more respect her qualities not her
policies or her philosophy a courage her
persistence her dedication
did you like her I am in awe of what she
did the policies you can argue with but
to sit in the hot seat I can't even
imagine having that steadfastness there
is a looking back at the Thatcher era
and saying well you know she did it she
cut taxes she balanced the budget she
sorted out all these problems great long
list of problems what why can't we learn
from that era and get somebody that will
do it the same job for us today